new this afternoon at four o'clock a
federal water shortage has been declared
now for lake mead we've been watching
this for several days now this is the
first time though declaration like this
has been announced since the reservoir
was created and that was way back in the
1930s joe muller is live near anne and
jones with what today's announcement
means for all of us joe
well lake mead supplies most of the
water here in southern nevada and as
this drought continues there's now an
even bigger push for conservation like
at this home here in las vegas where
they switched out their their yard for
fake turf here now today the bureau of
reclamation released the colorado river
basin 24-month study it is anticipated
that conditions will worsen in 2022 for
two decades lake mead's water levels
have been declining and right now it is
at 40 capacity a federal water shortage
declaration means more cuts for
downstream states along the colorado
river jacqueline gold regional director
for reclamation's lower colorado region
explains
arizona will see a delivery reduction of
about 18 percent
nevada's reduction will be 7
and mexico's reduction will be about 5
percent
with that 18 cut arizona will feel this
the worse specifically farmers in that
state here in nevada because we already
use less than we are given due to so
much conservation the cuts will not
actually reduce deliveries here now
because of the ongoing drought the
southern nevada water authority is
working with california to develop a
water recycling program now back out
here live as the levels continue to drop
at lake mead and this drought continues
they do warn of even more cuts in the
future so they are pushing for the
conservation as much as we can do like
this yard here in las vegas but we're
seeing a lot more people swapping out
their lawns they just for people to do
their part reporting live near ann and
jones joe moeller eight news now